imagina que pudieras cobrar un sueldo de
600 dólares al mes por no hacer
absolutamente nada has oído bien un
sueldo que cobraría por el mero hecho de
existir todos los meses está acá está el
gobierno te paga 600 dólares a ti ya
todos los ciudadanos de tu país no me he
vuelto loco
eso se llama renta básica universal
es una política defendida en mayor o
menor medida por muchos economistas como
por ejemplo milton friedman ya me puedo
imaginar lo que os estaréis preguntando
muchos de donde se saca el dinero para
pagar todo eso
qué sentido tiene a quién se le ha
ocurrido semejante locura pues lo cierto
es que finlandia ya ha empezado a
experimentar con eso de la renta básica
universal es solo un experimento pero ya
han corrido ríos de tinta y casi todos
bastante críticos hoy vamos a explicar
por qué
[Aplausos]
[Música]
finlandia es un país mundialmente
conocido por una cosa es la patria del
metal
[Música]
hablamos del país con la mayor densidad
de bandas de heavy metal per cápita para
que os hagáis una idea hay más de 600
bandas de metal por cada millón de
habitantes en otras palabras que si vais
a las fiestas de un pueblo de finlandia
no os van a tocar ni paquito el
chocolatero ni reggaeton en estas
latitudes incluso las abuelas agitan sus
melenas al ritmo de bandas como
stratovarius sonata arctica o night uy
pero vamos a dejar los cuernos y los
solos de guitarra a un lado lo cierto es
que durante años finlandia era algo así
como el hermano pobre de los países
nórdicos un país con pocas oportunidades
y muchísimos problemas de alcoholismo
sin embargo todo eso es historia hoy en
día
finlandia es uno de los países más ricos
de la eurozona y están a la vanguardia
en lo que se refiere a educación
hablamos de la patria que vio nacer a
los móviles de nokia oa videojuegos como
el angry birds
[Música]
sin embargo las cosas últimamente no van
demasiado bien en este país a ver no
podemos decir que estén en crisis ni
muchísimo menos pero está claro que este
país no pasa por su mejor momento
económico nokia que es la empresa
icónica de finlandia está en horas bajas
la principal exportación del país que es
el papel está bajando drásticamente y
uno de sus mayores socios comerciales
que es rusia tampoco está precisamente
en condiciones de comprar nada y que
creéis que hacen los holandeses cuando
su economía va mal pues no se les ocurre
nada mejor que hacer un experimento tal
vez uno de los experimentos políticos
más ambiciosos de la historia
finlandia considera introducir la renta
básica universal en 2017 ya sé lo que
estoy pensando seguro que finlandia
tiene un gobierno de extrema izquierda
verdad pues nada más lejos de la
realidad el primer ministro de finlandia
es este señor que veis aquí que se llama
juha sipila y que anteriormente era uno
de los empresarios más ricos del país
para que os hagáis una idea el gobierno
de finlandia ahora mismo es una
coalición que va desde el centro hasta
la derecha populista es más este
experimento está encuadrado dentro de un
paquete de medidas para acabar con el
gasto público es decir que el gobierno
finés quiere poner una renta básica
universal para recortar presupuesto
[Música]
como decíamos al principio todo esto no
es más que un experimento es decir no es
que finlandia haya dicho que a partir de
ahora le vayamos a dar a todo el mundo
560 euros al mes no lo que han hecho ha
sido juntar a dos mil personas y
probarlo durante dos años puede llegar a
funcionar algo así de verdad se puede
recortar gasto con una renta básica
universal cuál es el propósito real de
este experimento hoy vamos a responder a
esta pregunta pero antes vamos a ver un
poco de historia
many for nothing hay dos grandes
escuelas a la hora de defender la renta
básica universal por un lado tenemos a
los que defienden que todos los
ciudadanos de un país cobran un sueldo
muy generoso algo que se acercaría al
salario medio por ejemplo hace unos años
suiza
celebró un referéndum donde se proponía
una renta de unos 2.500 dólares por
ciudadano ese dinero es suficiente para
que mucha gente pudiera plantearse dejar
de trabajar y el resultado de esa
votación fue un rotundo no por qué pues
porque básicamente ese dinero no cae del
cielo
para que os hagáis una idea según un
estudio de la fundación bbva aplicar una
renta básica universal de este tipo en
españa nos obligaría a pagar hasta un
40% más de impuestos eso por no hablar
de lo que ocurre si la gente no trabaja
en otras palabras que es bastante
difícil defender una política de este
tipo ahora bien hay otra forma de
entender la renta básica universal
veréis según muchos economistas podría
ser un sustituto de las ayudas sociales
por ejemplo este señor que vais a ver
ahora se llama milton friedman que
aparte de tener un premio nobel de
economía es uno de los grandes
abanderados del libre mercado sin
embargo esto es lo que dice sobre una
hipotética renta básica o como él lo
llamaba impuesto negativo sobre la renta
y el impuesto negativo sobre la renta es
una propuesta para ayudar a los pobres
dándoles dinero que es lo que necesitan
en lugar de lo que tenemos ahora que
requiere que la gente se presente ante
un funcionario le diga lo que tiene sus
activos sus pasivos
luego le digan que se tienen que gastar
x dólares en alquiler x dólares en
comida etcétera etcétera veréis a día de
hoy todos los países conceden ayudas a
los más desfavorecidos desde
prestaciones por desempleo hasta cheques
de comida por ejemplo las familias más
pobres de república dominicana reciben
un cheque de 18 dólares todos los meses
para comprar alimentos en principio
puede parecer es una buena idea verdad
dónde está el problema pues que cada
familia tiene necesidades distintas y lo
mismo ocurre con otras ayudas por
ejemplo hay muchas ayudas condicionadas
a no tener trabajo es decir que en el
momento en lo que consigues un empleo
dejas de recibirlas según muchos
economistas esto desincentiva a mucha
gente a buscar trabajo hasta qué punto
tiene razón bueno pues eso daría para
otro vídeo pero lo cierto es que la
renta básica universal al menos como
sustituto de las ayudas sociales tiene
defensores hasta en el mundo de la
empresa
[Música]
y lo más dice que la renta básica
universal va a ser necesaria y os
preguntaréis es posible que funcione se
trata de una buena idea lo cierto es que
tampoco lo sabemos porque básicamente
nunca se ha probado hasta la fecha se
están haciendo varios experimentos en
ciudades como ontario en canadá o
barcelona en españa pero nadie ha
llegado tan lejos como finlandia pero
qué es lo que han hecho exactamente en
este país pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
el experimento finlandés en el año 2016
el llamado que la que es la seguridad
social finlandesa comenzó este
experimento escogieron de forma
aleatoria a 2000 personas que estaban
cobrando ayudas por parte del estado
para dos minutos válidos o gente con
algún tipo de baja laboral durante los
siguientes dos años estos dos mil
afortunados estuvieron o están
dependiendo cuando veáis este vídeo
cobrando 560 euros al mes y diréis
cuánto le ha costado esto al gobierno
pues la respuesta es nada por ejemplo
imagina que vives en helsinki en
finlandia y cobras una baja por
discapacidad una cantidad muy normal en
este país serían unos ochocientos
sesenta euros al mes
pues bien en este caso si estás cobrando
esta renta básica universal la baja por
discapacidad se te reduce a trescientos
euros y los otros 560 euros restantes
vendrían por este experimento y os
preguntaréis pero cuál es la diferencia
es decir que qué más da cobrar de una
forma o de la otra pues veréis si cobras
la baja por discapacidad el estado
dejará de pagarte en el momento en el
cual encuentres un trabajo sin embargo
la renta básica universal la puedes
cobrar hagas lo que hagas
[Música]
y ahora os preguntaréis pero porque los
medios de comunicación dicen que este
proyecto ha fracasado pues lo cierto es
que a principios de este año 2018 los
directores de esta iniciativa pidieron
al gobierno que ampliarán el programa es
decir que en lugar de dar quinientos
sesenta euros a gente que estaba
cobrando ayudas del estado se los dieran
también a otras 1.000 o 2.000 personas
que no están cobrando ningún tipo de
ayuda y ahí es donde el parlamento votó
en contra y esto no me lo invento yo de
hecho se puede consultar en la página
web del que la es decir de la seguridad
social finlandesa y está traducido
incluso al inglés es decir que para
algunos periodistas eso de confirmar las
fuentes debe de ser una cosa muy del
2015 pero aquí viene la pregunta del
millón a que no adivina quién es uno de
los mayores críticos de la renta básica
universal exacto
según el sindicato más grande de
finlandia la renta básica universal no
sirve para nada en resumen que hasta
principios del año 2019 no tendremos
ningún dato sobre este experimento pero
por qué hay tantas críticas pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
un estudio sesgado la primera pregunta
que se estaréis haciendo es de verdad es
suficiente con 560 euros para vivir en
finlandia y la respuesta es que no el
salario medio en este país es de tres
mil quinientos euros es decir que esos
quinientos sesenta euros en finlandia
serían el equivalente a unos trescientos
euros en españa para que os hagáis una
idea solo el alquiler de un piso pequeño
en helsinki cuesta más de 800 euros
una simple colonoscopia en un hospital
normal puede costar unos 700 euros es
decir que en el mejor de los casos esta
renta básica universal sería una simple
ayuda en ningún caso sería un sustituto
de los servicios públicos ni muchísimo
menos de un salario
y os preguntaréis pero cuánto podría
costar al erario público es decir
suponiendo que dejará de ser un
experimento y a partir de 2019 todos los
finlandeses cobrarán una renta básico
universal de cuánto dinero estaríamos
hablando pues estaríamos hablando de más
de tres mil millones de euros y en un
país tan pequeño como finlandia eso sí
que es una cantidad considerable y por
supuesto si ampliáramos la ayuda
podríamos hablar de riesgos financieros
mucho mayores
pero este no es el único problema veréis
parte del interés de este estudio es ver
lo que ocurre si damos dinero a cambio
de nada
es decir si tú cobras 560 euros este es
o no estés en el paro seguirás buscando
trabajo o no y lo cierto es que el
estudio también está viciado en este
sentido porque todos los participantes
saben que es una ayuda que solo dura dos
años es decir que es muy probable que
los resultados de este estudio estén
sesgados desde el principio y por eso
las críticas a este experimento están
llegando por todos los flancos
[Música]
la ocde vida finlandia que abandoné la
renta básica y rediseñe los programas de
ayudas sociales
pero ahora vamos a cambiar de tema
porque antes de terminar el vídeo de hoy
vamos a empezar una nueva sección en
visual política veréis últimamente
recibimos un montón de preguntas muy
interesantes a través de nuestro patrón
preguntas que seguro que más de uno se
ha hecho alguna vez así que hemos
pensado que mejor que responder por un
mensaje privado vamos a responder por
aquí hoy tenemos a oscar ceballos zúñiga
que nos pregunta por la bonanza
económica de portugal con un gobierno de
izquierdas a ver oscar lo primero que
hay que dejar claro es que los gobiernos
de izquierdas pueden ser tan buenos o
tan malos en la economía como los de
derechas aquí en visual político hemos
contado como el gobierno laborista de
nueva zelanda en los años 80 sacó al
país de la crisis en el caso de portugal
han hecho muchos recortes en
infraestructura y luego han dado muchas
facilidades fiscales en distintos
sectores estratégicos por ejemplo si
eres autónomo y te estableces en
territorio portugués tienes unas
vacaciones fiscales de varios años esto
lógicamente ha ayudado a que
muchas pequeñas empresas se instalan en
el país a esto hay que sumarle que en
general toda europa está creciendo
portugal incluida si crecen más pueden
recaudar más impuestos y eso explica por
qué están saliendo de la crisis
en cualquier caso llevamos varios meses
trabajando en un vídeo sobre portugal
donde trabajaremos todos estos temas
mucho más a fondo gracias por tu
pregunta a oscar y a todos los demás si
queréis consultarnos cualquier duda os
vemos en patrio
[Música]
mientras tanto ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros creéis que este experimento de
finlandia servirá para sacar
conclusiones útiles
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a visual por
tyc y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]